rolling welcome to the 24/7 live stream
if we spirits come out of this man I
think BuzzFeed is the worst news outlet
in the world hi there I'm Aria and from
August 20th to August 27th I streamed my
life non-stop for seven days and it was
simultaneously one of the most
fulfilling and destructive weeks of my
life as far as broadcasting goes it's
just like TV on the internet and I think
what it needs is to have something
that's made for the media this will
replace television as we know it now in
real life streaming is a growing
phenomenon where people live stream
their everyday activities to the world
to begin my week I met up with one of
the most popular IRL streamers today
Asian Andy what's the most money you've
made in a single stream it's a 72 hour
stream like non-stop we'd made like
$28,000 I rose pretty cool I feel like
people been watching like TV and it just
doesn't feel as genuine or real so they
just kind of want something that feels
like more part of their life we're about
ready to go live look I like you too the
honors of streams live I don't know if
anyone can see us people are there are
people chatting all right it's
fascinating thing about how far
technology and entertainment has evolved
I mean I was just wearing this light
live you streaming kit with unlimited
IRL data on my back and it's crazy to
think how this tiny little box at the
heart of it could transmit such
high-quality footage in real time to
viewers all around the world just to
watch me it's actually makes me a little
worried just weird I don't know what
what I might say or do I feel like now
I'm constantly monitored what are the
challenges to the IRL streaming it's
like emotionally exhausting how many of
yours you get get your work cut out for
you know IRL should be like the easiest
job you just like live your life and
like you get paid money for it but like
there's so much more to it nobody
arrives you do contact constantly feel
pressure to entertain people so we
really stress a little bit yeah so for
seven days I need to find a way to
entertain yeah
121 watchin always feel like eating
watch sometimes gonna suck C yes s don't
say where you're eating you'll get tons
of calls you know they actually know
where we are
can't really have like a lone tongue
dude good luck this week I'm actually a
fairly private person so I already knew
that one of my biggest challenges was
going to be having no privacy for an
entire week the viewership is much
harder than I thought when I was live I
basically didn't stop talking because
with people watching I always felt like
I had to be on for them like I'm like
completely lost fine yes Arianna you're
gonna watch me sleep okay yes
the next day was the first time I
brought the live you kit into the office
and people at work were definitely
intrigued by it morning everyone I just
wanted a little attention I think
there's something very addictive about
the nature of IRL and its ephemeral
quality I mean why do we post things on
social media we post pictures on
Instagram because we want to get those
likes we want to get those comments we
want that affirmation and with IRL you
get that in real time I
that afternoon I brought in brother
Carlos an exorcist I had previously
worked with I like blueberries
blueberries oh yeah I eat blueberries
all day long brother Carlos has
experience in live-streaming himself so
I thought I'd pick his brain to see if
there were any way he could help me I
have already minister for 12 hours just
to let you know you've done a 12 hour
movie non-stop how can you physically do
that without killing your voice it's
supernatural so you know I feel like God
is blessing me so I can continue on
without having to take any breaks you
know you have God on your side and I'm
wondering can you bless me in any way
for this week father I asked for now
that you bless our yeah grant him energy
so he can handle all his tasks and be a
success in what he is doing this week
thank you amen amen
and of course to keep viewers
entertained I brought in a couple of
Ghost Hunters I know I just eat
blueberries all day long
join him in some livestream exorcisms
surface now there was in Jesus mighty
need come up to the surface come up to
the surface right now come out in Jesus
name I'm commanding you pelvic bones hip
bones adjust and once again just seeing
that live-chat fly as viewers are
entertained it just gives this unique
rush he's God's creation God's child do
you take your nasty dirty hands off of
him but throughout all of this though
there was one name that viewers just
kept bringing up it seemed every five
minutes someone was telling me to go
meet ice Poseidon go see I said he
wanted me to see a big streamer tomorrow
visit nice I don't think my visit I see
them it was nice to sight in farther but
some of you might be wondering who the
hell is ice Poseidon trouble on the
tarmac as an American Airlines flight is
grounded for a bomb threat an online
personality somebody who streams video
online says it was a bomb threat and it
was a prank he says he was the target
so someone pretended to be you called in
and said I have a bomb yeah
Paul de Nino otherwise known as ice
Poseidon is arguably one of the most
successful IRL streamers in the world a
lightning rod of controversy known for
pushing the boundaries of IRL Paul
single-handedly built the CX Network a
channel of IRL streamers for his
community of followers known as the
purple army and at the behest of many
many viewers on Wednesday afternoon my
friends Alex Ysidro and I set out to
meet him if you guys are just tuning in
we're going to see ice right now I got
some KFC for him the only slight issue
was that while we had his address he had
no idea we were coming how confident are
you guys are you anything where we're
gonna meet him but once again that's the
power of IRL chad is flowing
the chat managed to find a way to let
him know we were headed over Oh
fantastic Thank You Phineas and shortly
after we were face-to-face thank you for
having us over my chat with Paul was
unlike any interview I'd ever done
normally an interviewee tends to filter
themselves on camera about him I think
was beauty so makes a lot of videos
really talk about the rest it's like he
will self-admittedly say and do things
to get a reaction out of people on and
off stream so many ways Paul is the
physical embodiment of online trolling
culture and because of that his dreams
and many other IRL streams tend to
attract viewers from that realm it's a
culture that definitely stands in stark
contrast to the values and ideology of a
company like BuzzFeed and its audience
so this encounter was like a strange
meeting between two polar ends of the
internet landscape I don't care what you
think about me as long as my community
isn't actually serious and why the [ __ ]
they say all just trolls okay now there
are some people on reddit or whatever
that I can tell or like actually [ __ ]
racists or actually sex people [ __ ]
knows people IRL is rooted in the side
of the Internet we don't typically dive
into and so that's why it was important
for me to get that experience because
while it would be easy for us to label
all IRL viewers as just online trolls
there's something more to it
you know beneath all that trolling there
must be a genuine reason why they keep
tuning in right
your channel on the ZX network before I
left Paul decided to put me on the CX
network meaning that his community would
have regular access to my stream now you
really need to experience what it's like
to be a streamer dreaming with a couple
hundred viewers is fun sure me what a
couple thousand years is stressful
so as the week was already beginning to
wear away at me I was now faced with the
added pressure of having to cater to an
audience of hundreds if not thousands
more than I ever thought I would the
next morning I woke up to almost 300
viewers tuned in just to watch me sleep
and the anxiety of philia need to be
performative in front of all these
viewers really began to get to me I
wanted to bring in someone who has
experienced being in the public eye so
as one does I brought in Lucy Hale
talented actress and singer known for
her role in Pretty Little Liars as Aria
it makes me a little nervous when things
are live when you're out and you know
people might be watching you do you ever
feel like you have to be on in a certain
way I am aware that there are more eyes
on me but I try to not let it affect me
if that makes sense
I'm always just trying to be like
authentically myself and like sometimes
maybe I'm like charming and funny but
I'm not all the time like well I think
you're doing I think you're a delight
you know what Aria we can agree on that
aria an aria but for as much as Lucy and
I were getting along
I love the bible' I really do the thing
in the back of my mind was content
content it's a message that IRL
streamers will often receive when
viewers want to see something new or fun
and so I thought they want content I'll
give them and my co-workers some content
we really nailed it
wait did you pay these people to come
get in our line for the live stream
everyone's just excited to be here yeah
obviously how'd you like the lemonade
stand it was great
teenage ki was standing over Lucy helm
this has been a really interesting day I
honestly didn't know what we were doing
and you pleasantly surprised me
but even after Lucy left I felt this
pressure to keep entertaining all these
viewers so I just kept that content
coming this is a 7-eleven milk bar mm I
betrayed you Doss with it so you paid
$22 too much content Jesus you weren't
you weren't excessive I was hooked
because I was beginning to build very
real relationships with my viewers and
wanted them to keep watching watching
stream they're like some people that are
just keeping watching there's other
people didn't hear that that have been
here since day one and looking back I
didn't realize just how much of a toll
it was starting to take on me we were
having dinner at a Thai restaurant when
we saw that a thousand people were just
watching us
and it's then that I finally realized
just how crazy this experience was
becoming my challenge and I'm definitely
exhausted kind of getting definitely
burnout but little did I know it was
still to come
[Music]
there Davis I had a meeting Friday
morning so I gave this dream to julissa
for an hour and unfortunately with my
channel now bringing in all kinds of
viewers that's when the full brunt of
IRL toxicity came to the surface okay
they say nasty [ __ ] yeah their root is
how I don't care you see while I had
been able to keep the trolls at bay
unfortunately with me now out of the
picture the troll saw an opportunity and
took it
[Music]
and while these weren't my regular
viewers and there were other viewers
saying positive things I just I have to
acknowledge that that that is truly the
dark side of IRL I'm over this that's
one thing I think you should be scared
of it's like the chat is getting a
little bit you know trollee and like
potentially toxic that could reflect on
you and your co-workers might be like
damn this is the kind of thing that you
created oh my god are you for me it was
more that I chose to sign up to be
exposed to all this my co-workers didn't
and I remember feeling just so guilty
this is a lot to do for seven days by
that point I think it was apparent to
everyone around me including my manager
the week was hitting me hard
say listen child I know this has been
like really tiring this time I want you
to be able to feel rested to go for
division
oh hey Samara they like that kind of sad
I don't get it this is Alex Alison and
Oh Alex Wyse and youtuber came along
with us that afternoon and I was
completely decided to go to Petco to
pick up a hamster to surprise one of our
co-workers and I was just zoned out she
looks like Ari like really tired but
then of course there was more drama
because the co-worker wasn't at the
office and then we were pulled aside
because for some reason we used the
company car to buy the hamster I was
just so stressed out I was running on
fumes and now we had to go all the way
back to Petco during rush hour to return
and repurchase the hamster not to
mention that I also felt terrible for
the hamster for having to go through all
this
guys Aria is actually pretty stressed
about this and even though it was all
okay in the end
I was just physically and mentally wiped
out are a serious question do you regret
making this video and I still had three
days to go
after sleeping in for most of Saturday
that night nanda wanted to go out and I
thought since I'd relaxed a bit sure
I'll go and that was just a terrible
decision because mentally and physically
I was still just not in the right place
to be socializing and at this point the
livestream was definitely affecting my
relationships with my friends and
co-workers not wanting to be on stream
or not wanting me to stream that's
terrifying
and so I was caught in a very
uncomfortable situation between my
friends and my viewers who would you
rather do and I wasn't gonna turn off
the stream with just a couple of days
left to go and I just kept thinking to
myself why did I come out
[Music]
I mean there's always so many times I
could deal with getting called out for
having the stream with me like you hate
the stream I get it I was just so
drained and it was obvious my brother
who was watching the stream even called
me to tell me I should go home yeah I'm
gonna head home in a bit I even got some
text from Asian Andy who had also been
watching and while my friends were still
joking around and thinking it was the
viewers making me feel off that wasn't
the case
[Music]
yes what is going on right now you know
it looked me as stuff look at this okay
I'm not good at vocalizing my feelings
because I never want to feel like I'm a
burden on other people and so I could
have been a lot clearer but I just felt
like my friends my co-workers they just
didn't get what I was going through but
the chat did
[Music]
because these people saw more of me that
week than anyone else did so they could
tell how uncomfortable of a situation I
was in I really began to realize just
how much of an effect these digital
strangers could have on me and while I
wasn't ultimately worried about my
friends because I knew we'd be okay once
the stream was done I was still left to
ask him myself did I really want to say
goodbye to my viewers the next day after
getting some much-needed rest to gain
some fresh perspective I met up with
sweet Aaron a female IRL streamer what
attracted me to this whole thing is the
Wild West aspect of live-streaming
it's literally like an uncultivated land
where anything can happen and the
uncertainty of it is what makes it
simultaneously thrilling as well as
Charlie doing my streams forced me to
confront parts of myself that I didn't
want to
it's like virtual therapy where you have
a mirror up to yourself and you have to
either change go out or run away from
who you are and you bring people along
your journey with you who will either
love you or hate you but it's worth in
the end we can
impact people's lives in a positive
happy way and give people hope that they
too can accept themselves more to me
that's what it is it's a real authentic
expression of human life I think it'd be
ignorant to say if IRL is good or bad
it's much like the rest of the internet
nebulous and blurry you can see the very
worst of the internet if I'm showing
where the [ __ ] I am on livestream then
it's completely fine to swat a [ __ ]
plane you're delusional but there's also
potential for so much good
oh wow thank you I think it's a real
cure for people who have social problems
like depression for like anxiety because
I have like the same kind of condition
as you kind of autism yeah thank you
guys so much for being there watching me
because that final night my viewers
convinced me to turn on text-to-speech a
feature used by IRL streamers where
people can donate money along with a
message to be played aloud
I remember bracing myself for a lot of
inappropriate messages but I wasn't
ready for some other ones I actually got
your stream was the best thing out of my
week Aria thank you for putting your
life on pause for this video thanks for
being you Aria heart you actually are
what more streamers should be like
you're awesome thanks don't forget us I
get the feeling you are going to move on
from streaming and go back to your
previous routines that last donation was
right we are a family now don't abandon
us hope you realize we are more than
just content for an article of video
hope you can see us as a friend I was
surprised by how bittersweet the last
day it was I don't think my co-workers
understood it they just saw it as a
relief for me for them so I stated 4:30
you have our arunya bag yeah but I don't
think he understood how hard it would be
for me because this was a really unique
experience you had to live to get know
how severe your heart shouldn't break
yeah I miss you too
most streamers don't do a non-stop
week-long stream but because I did my
viewers saw every side of me in a way I
don't think most people truly are you
gonna continue it levy streaming going
forward people kept asking me if I'd
still stream every now and then we're
heading into the final stretch guys and
if they'd ask me about a week prior my
answer would have been easy it's been
it's been a road and this goodbye is
actually harder than I thought it'd be
yeah I should I say thank you for this
experience thank you for watching
but if he'd ask me now if I'd ever go
back into the crazy world of IRL will I
last you again
you
you